and finally new rolled Donald Trump must
admit that of all his reversals
Hippocrates and 180s his condemnation
this week of Vicente Fox for using foul
language is the most ridiculous of all I
think it's a disgusting thing that he
said and I could tell you I would not
use that word talk about the pot calling
the kettle orange listen to this but
it's political she said he's a
they're ripping their out of
the sea we can't get a school
built in Brooklyn you're not gonna raise
that priceless I'm gonna bomb
the out of them listen your
we're gonna tax you twenty
five percent yes something certainly has
changed in American political discourse
oh sure Dick Cheney once told a senator
to go himself and Joe Biden called
Obamacare a big deal
but those comments were off-mike not
intended for public consumption and
considered gaffes but when Andrew Dice
Trump speaks
he doesn't even try to clean it up and
the voters have decided that not only do
they not mind their leaders swearing
they kind of like it
they kind of like it when a politician
drops the facade and talks the way we
all really talk but just so we all know
where this is headed
I would like tonight to show you what a
future president is going to look like
delivering the State of the Union
address in the not-too-distant future
the President of the United States
mr. speaker madam vice president fellow
citizens I stand before you tonight to
report that the state of our union is
awesome now thanks to the
programs we put in place inflation has
been kicked in the taint
we are job creating like a
and our deficit is shrinking like a
on a cold morning but I know I know that
even though the economy is strengthening
and the stock market is up too many
working families still feel like they're
taking it in the ass and that needs
to stop
now here with us tonight is Bob Huggins
from Park Ridge New Jersey and his story
is America's story Bob busted his
nutsack for 24 27 years assembling brake
pads until the company decided to move
to Mexico and Bob was shit-canned and
left holding his dick in his hand which
is why if this Congress asked me to
raise taxes I'll say no and they'll push
me and I'll say no and they'll push
again and I will say to them lick my
balls no new taxes
also with us tonight is Shirley Fowler a
widowed mother of four who along with
her husband bud worked hard and played
by the rules but bud was killed in a
fertilizer plant explosion due to a
rollback in workplace regulations and
now Shirley's life is a shitshow
by day she Labor's for minimum wage
wiping down the sneeze guard at Shakey's
and by night she works the pole at a
country-music strip club called puss and
boots giving tug jobs in the parking lot
her extra cash
let us make this pledge tonight in the
richest country in the world no one
should have to do a lap dance or suck a
dick to make ends meet now last year
when Diane and I were campaigning in
Ohio I met a sixth grade teacher in
Chagrin Falls and well she looked like
you'd had a hard day so I gave her a hug
and asked her what was wrong she pointed
her classroom and said to me mr.
president these kids don't know
they deserve an education that doesn't
suck balls we can do better we also must
do better caring for our wounded
warriors like Air Force veteran Jeff
Monroe who lost a leg fighting in Iraq
but instead of bitching about it like a
little
Jeff worked with Blade Runner
technicians and this year ran in the
Boston Marathon
it is for soldiers like sergeant Monroe
the tonight I am asking this Congress
for a hundred billion dollars in
increased military spending let every
nation know that if you with the
United States you are with the
most Bulls out badass swinging dicks the
world has ever seen and we will not
hesitate to skull you tear your
head off and down your neck
my friends there are those in these
uncertain times who say America's best
days are behind us but I say that
that that that thank you
god bless you and God bless the United
States of America